hi I'm Ryan right yeah I'm Jerry I'm
Sally
welcome to reasons to see what would
give you reasons to seek normally we'd
give you reasons to Z and not to see a
movie that were you know reviewing but
today we're gonna do something a little
different again we're gonna talk about
guardians of the galaxy together because
someone wants us to and I don't remember
your name wish we had modern technology
so we could figure
yeah we can be able to have the ability
look it up guardians of the galaxy this
has got to be like the biggest trailer
that's gonna come out this year for some
reason so far yeah it's huge
everybody had a little jimmy kimmel
thing about it yeah that's big yeah but
yeah no I love the whole idea we just
the trailer alums awesome like it starts
off like kinda with this funny offbeat
kind of humor and introducing these
characters and then it just goes in like
crazy [ __ ] action you're like this is
a whole adventure to all these cool
characters ah then it ends up that funny
music and stuff like it just ends on the
right now like the trailer alone
deserves a lot of credit well yeah I
mean it
I like that Marvel seems to be embracing
a sort of quirky er more humorous you
know tone because I mean this is a James
Gunn movie and James Gunn made like
super and slither I'm a really big fan
of his style and he has a good knack for
work but you know with an edge yes so I
think he's the right guy for this you
can make badass stuff super it was cool
in a lot of ways and so with slither he
knows how to do a film like this and
what I like about it too is that yes
it's part of the Marvel film universe
but and it's gonna be including The
Avengers as well so yeah but it doesn't
feel like an Avengers movie like how a
lot of them are starting it's like
they're showing a separate team and
they're showing like hey this isn't just
another character we're gonna throw in
the adventures oh it's a court here
alternate after doing the trailer
reaction I didn't really know what it
was and
so I had a lot of the subscribers
explain it to me so you guys have you
guys know what it is like what about the
movie do you think it's gonna be like
the comics
or what are you excited about the comics
- I don't know [ __ ] about the comics
that's on her Call Me box
all these guys were like here's the
whole story for you it's like paragraphs
upon paragraphs and I'm like don't got
time to read it but I appreciate that
you guys are trying to educate us no
that's cool the answer but why didn't
you guys do that for me I saw you guys
you guys talked to me too and you guys
are like nice vid but her you're like
here's my life story and why I love
guardians of the galaxy I think it's
because people like nerd girls and they
want to make you into a nerd when you
happen to be a good-looking nerd girl
she is a nerd girl she's a total nerd
Sally lumenok oh my god I'm really
excited for a couple of things
specifically at three specific now you
know there's a lot that was sad for not
probably queue number seven for Bradley
campus a record yeah he's gonna be the
raccoon and that raccoon looks [ __ ]
tight that's right I brought that word
back like it starts off like that's
weird and funny and then you see him in
the trailer he's just shooting the gun
and stuff you're like that reaction is
gonna keep some raccoons are badass
Cooper was pretty cool it's like goober
Luke and wait for that Vin Diesel that's
grouped I don't know [ __ ] about group
and everyone keeps talking about it and
isn't Zoe Saldana good morning oh yeah
she's hot hot what do stuff they've got
john c reilly and they've got Benicio
del Toro and they they even have Peter
Serafinowicz in the back what a bunch of
a-holes which is the guy who they dubbed
the voice for Ray Parker in storms
episode 100 roommate in Shaun of the
Dead and john c reilly is from
stepbrothers how can you forget sorry
sally has a smoker's cough that's what
it is you a smoker no I don't if you
call me no no 19 he's gonna watch he's
one of our biggest fans she's gonna
write a whole album about you now
I'm gonna cable tonight mm-hmm
I try to make it song about myself Oh
fire I'm gonna burn you at the stake
and how could you forget Chris [ __ ]
Pratt he looks awesome he is the man
needs day and I know and this is funny
cuz I'm Parks and Rec he just plays like
a stupid dude but he's great at it I
remember watching him the first time I
ever saw him was in uh at Jason Segel
movie five maybe five-year engagement
and I thought he was great in that I was
like who is this dude what he's been
everywhere this year aligns like he was
in the what he was the mink
he was Emma in the lego movie he was in
her he's in this now he was just Parks
and Rec do Parks and Rec he was in zero
dark thirty yeah yeah and he got cut
damn you see that eight-pack yet and
that chest is biceps no I want to look
just like you Pratt I'm just gonna say
this judging by this trailer and any
trailers you know or worries them always
to me but this could be my favorite
movie yeah it just seems like it has the
fixin's okay here's the big question do
you think it'll beat out spider-man do
you mean at the box up yeah oh it's hard
to say because spider-man is like huge
and guardians of the galaxy is something
that I can learn well here's the thing
even though I don't know what grains
become I actually think it will just
because the hype around it is bigger
than the hyper on it's bigger it's it's
a very new movie and I think a lot of
people were really disappointed in the
first fighter man so I think maybe some
of them will wait to just watch it on
DVD I mean yeah the second one looks
awesome but because so many people are
disappointed with the first one it might
not I have no idea that would I could be
wrong
I think the marketing for its really
good for this i yeah well they have to I
mean after you make up through it
they're not gonna [ __ ] up the marketing
that anyways United trailer was
brilliant like I loved it because it's
like scenes from the movie and it's all
the bad guys
it's a Man of Steel to one man and
Superman Oh yours
so that's what happens when you get the
power of Superman and Batman in one I'm
just excited for ant-man the Apple run
it doesn't I said you're right ant-man
why it's this guy who collects a trance
and like he uses them to kill people
that's real it's a real movie coming out
yeah you're right Willard dude come on
don't you ever know how to play along
no it's a new smartest describe the plot
of Willard I know it ants that's why
yeah it's it's up it's a marvel but yeah
we got to get going cuz we got [ __ ] to
do but thank you guys for tuning in
thank you guys a lot
we love you dudes and girls and thank
you for welcoming Sally so much to the
channel she is a fantastic person yeah
really hot high five really sexy yeah
that's that Sally's theme song actually
everywhere she goes Chuck yeah she
actually runs a tribe it's crazy
yeah it's bunch of redheads that's what
tribal redhead yeah it's like a b-movie
exploit University how they handle the
different frats and sororities in
Missouri's was the pink girls and they
were all like redheads in purple yeah
they're actually really evil that's you
and dudes and gals check out his reasons
to Jerry playlist oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
hilarious not a big fan of the first
video with the second and third check
that [ __ ] out oh I have a video up of me
and Ryan answering a bunch of weird
questions
well I answer them he just kind of makes
me feel awkward so check that out oh my
god
yeah and subscribe to this channel if
you haven't subscribed yet and talk
about card Ian's a galaxy with me and
how do you think Sally is and hit me up
about we actually talk back that's what
I think is cool you know people a lot of
guys act surprised when we're like we
comment back and I'm like I feel like a
douche if I didn't comment that someone
took the time and comment on the video
and watch the whole video I mean you
should like Tommy
but you know when people comment with
things to say that are like kill
yourself yeah I even comment back to
those people and you guys are so nice to
I gotta say that you subscribers are
awesome I always heard about like how
everyone on youtubes a dick before have
you put up a channel and then like I'm
not experiencing that today you guys are
awesome likey I love doing this channel
something because I get to interact with
you guys
Sally Romania cool YouTube channel name
domain anything that's like your show
that Animaniacs back with Sally yeah and
Pinky and the brain mm-hmm what is a
genius this is the same same the
laboratory mice their genes have been
spliced I didn't have Cartoon Network